i the undersigned being the acting
returning officer at the election held
on Thursday the 7th of May 2015 do
hereby give notice that the number of
votes cast for each candidate at the
election is as follows Barry
Raymond John justice for men and boys 63
done
Francis John known as Frank done UK
Independence Party five thousand six
hundred and seventy-four Epton stone
Stanley known as Stan captain story
Liberal Democrats 2120 Kerwin David
Green Party 1544 Palmer Nicholas Douglas
known as Nick former Labour Party
nineteen thousand eight hundred and
seventy-six sugery Anna Mary the
Conservative Party candidate twenty four
thousand
the number of ballot papers rejected was
as follows voting for more candidates
than the voter was entitled to 90
writing by which the votes that could be
identified by being unmarked or wholly
void for uncertainty 105 and I hereby
declare that Anna Mary super II has been
duly elected
I'm very conscious of the hour
it's what was gone five o'clock in the
morning so I won't interfere very long
route to you in your team thank you very
much for the way that you have conducted
not only this election but obviously
this very long count because of course
you've had to make sure that all the
papers for tomorrow's borough and parish
and Town Council's have been separated
so thank you very much deal team the
police and everybody who's taken part
today and indeed throughout the night
will all be back tomorrow at 12:00 at
home I'm not going to say very much
other than to thank the people of Rock
stay for reelecting me and there isn't
quite a big majority which is quite
shocking I think that it's really
important that you always reference
represent all the communities within
your constituency whether it's people
here in beastin who've been affected so
badly by the tram works whether it's in
our great times of Kimberley and staple
third and it is interesting that I'm
told but actually the increase in the
vote for the Conservatives was right
across the whole of the constituency and
I'm very proud and pleased about that
and I have to thank my brilliant speed
aprox no 2015 and I hope everybody will
see that at last the Conservatives said
this constituency absolutely represent
everybody of all ages and all
backgrounds so that distributor it's
undoubtedly the case that there was a
fear factor
I think people genuinely didn't want to
see a Prime Minister of Ed Miliband and
they didn't want labour to wreck our
economy but I think there were positive
reasons not just the work the
campaigning I've been doing notably to
save our green belt and I hope that all
our councillors of whatever persuasion
they are here very clearly I believe the
people of this borough have said that
they do not want development on our
green belt and I think there was another
positive message and it's actually a
recognition of the last five years of
this government this coalition
government's great achievements in
relation to the economy building a
stronger economy so it can benefit
everybody in ours
and I look forward to playing my part
not just for this constituency at a part
of that program in the next five years
to come
thank you everybody